with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller Von Miller
[Music]
howdy guys this is Von Miller and
welcome to this week's Von cast it's
honor and a privilege to to do this
every week with you guys and this week
is going to be a special episode for you
guys
um before I get to my my guest this week
um I'll talk a little bit about my
guests before I get to them this is one
of my favorite players in the entire
league
um I've been watching them since he came
into the league been watching them since
you've been in the league like this is
my guy but before I you know step into
that you know I want to take a little
bit to really address you know my injury
and you know what happened
um without like going all the way into
it of course but you know this is Devon
cast and I know a lot of people you know
love and care about your boy so you know
I just wanted to address that I didn't
want to just jump over there and act
like you know I never got hurt or
anything like that I did get hurt
um you know the news is not the best of
news but it's definitely not the worst
of news
um it's kind of like in the middle
um you know I didn't tear my ACL that
was the the huge you know part of it
um but you know I do have some uh
lateral meniscus damage and it's gonna
have to be addressed but I I do feel
like I can you know play through that so
I'm just gonna wait a little bit
wait a little bit let the let the
swelling go down for about you know
seven to ten days and you know hopefully
right before the Jets game you know I
will be back and of course it's it's
gonna be like you know I'm not oh you
know of course it's gonna be something
that I had to push through which I've
done before
um you know I've been here before I've
battled through injuries battle through
knee injuries before so you know I feel
confident it's only been about five days
since the injury and each and every day
you know working with the training staff
I feel better and better about you know
my situation so like I said before it's
not you know
the best news that you could possibly
get but it's definitely not the worst
news
um you know I will say on top of that
too like you know I signed up to be a
Buffalo Bill for a long time and you
know I want to do my best for my
teammates
um and I'm gonna do my best for this
organization and the fans and I want to
put myself in a situation to be able to
produce and be able to go out there and
do what I do each and every week so if
I'm out there you know that I'm ready to
go and I feel totally confident about my
injury I feel totally confident about
where I'm at I'm not just gonna go out
there just you know for enough for a
superhero
um game or anything like that I feel
like you know you're 12 I don't have to
you know do things like that but if I'm
out there you know I'm feeling 100 and
I'm ready to go um I think one of the
toughest Parts about being injured is
just
it's just not being
for me it's just not being with my
teammates like not being in the mix with
my teammates not being in the rotation
with my teammates and not going through
that everyday struggle and that everyday
grind to to build and to try to uh
really go out there and fight for a win
and and not be able to be in the locker
room with everybody and laugh and joke
and you know that's that's what I miss
the most not being in a meeting room
like I got to go to rehab all day every
day not being able to joke and you know
bump around with you guys even though I
have a smile on my face and I'm you know
I feel very good about where I'm at I
just want to be in the mix man I came
here for a reason you know I came here
to win a Super Bowl I didn't come here
just to you know hang out and you know
uh Slap Ass or you know do anything like
that I came here for a reason so
whenever I'm you know I'm not able to
you know go out there and produce that's
what affects me the most but I'm doing
everything I can I I can tell you this
you have not seen the last of Von Miller
um I'm gonna miss this week but I think
every other week after this you know I
should be able to I should be able to
give it a shot I shouldn't feel good
about it and um
you know that that injury was crazy
because
I do like a little side swipe and I
stepped inside
and it was just like a little inside
stunt to the B Gap you know Sewell he
kind of gave me a chicken kind of float
he gave me a check to the outside
shoulder I floated inside and as soon as
I started to get up field like
the guys uh the guy is nobody's fault
but my foot was stepped on and his
weight just kind of caved in on the
outside of my knee and at the same time
I was going forward so it just created
like this buckling motion and um I'm
truly blessed and fortunate to not you
know have any other serious damage but
it was a tough injury and this is a
warrior Sport and you know one thing I
would never ever do is say why me
because
God has blessed me in so many different
ways man
um you know just to be able to have this
vodcast with you know you guys and this
guest that I'm about to bring up like
that is a blessing in itself you know to
be a part of this team and you know to
be in a situation where I can still go
out there and do what I do at a future
date man it's an extreme blessing so I'm
grateful I'm happy I don't want nobody
feeling sorry for me like when I signed
I signed a six year deal man it don't
feel sorry for me man I promise you I'm
gonna be all right I swear to God I
would be good but you know I just gotta
fight through it man and I'll be back
rehab is going good I'm feeling good I
think the mental aspect of it is really
the most important thing whenever you're
getting hurt as soon as you get hurt you
know it's easy to fall into this ball of
self uh pity and and feeling sorry for
yourself and and depression like this
that's those are all natural things but
not me I'm good
I I I I always choose to look at the
positive side of things and um because I
just feel like your eyes are better over
here just because you think positive and
you and you believe in positive things
doesn't always mean positive things will
happen but I just choose to live like
this is just my life I'm I just choose
to live on this this positive side of
things I choose to always go right
instead of left I choose to surround
myself around positive people positive
energy and that's just my choice man so
that is my update on my injury and
without any further ado
he's got it I got coming up here he
could easily have 35 sacks
a season maybe even more 40 sacks what
we play we play 17 games you know two
sacks a game like he could go crazy bro
I'm telling you he could go crazy each
and every week um the offenses
just choose to have all 11 people check
for this guy each each and every week
so you know it you know he got a fight
through five or six guys to get there
and he's still able to go out there and
dominate
um each and every week I'm a fan of the
sport I'm a fan of our craft past
Russian I'm a huge fan of this guy he's
a he's a he's a fellow Texas Aggie he's
a a former overall pick in the 2017
draft two-time first team All-Pro
last month he became the Cleveland
Browns
all-time franchise sack leader with 62
and a half career sacks and I think that
says it all this is my guess miles
Garrett clap it up on my boy
miles how's it going bro yeah it's going
well brother it's great to hear the
update because you know that that
positive talk and you know your your
nature you know just it's just uplifting
as it is man man I I am good man and I
had great examples you know before me
you know from guys that have dealt with
injury before man you you've dealt with
injury before you got guys like Tom
Brady and DeMarcus Ware like you know
I'm good man I'm in a great situation
but how did you spend your day off
man most of my day off really was just
you know relaxing with my dog was
watching watching some of the World Cup
watch USA get that win Advance Into The
Knockout round
play some Call of Duty you know play
with the boys uh well yesterday we had a
little day off too so played played God
of War
um
well they're just you know chilling
around the house get some rest from this
recovery treatment gotta work out in you
know just trying to don't stay stay
grounded stay around the house
are you a PC guy or are you console guy
I'm a PC guy you know Master race me too
man me too man I gotta get your Gamertag
so we can link up on some of those war
zone games on your free time it's crazy
because you know doing a little research
on my free time
I like to play golf you know I like to
hit the golf course I like to play golf
I'm not saying I'm good at golf but I
like to be out there with my boys and
hang out on in your free time you like
to play pick up basketball in the off
season
do you think that of course I already
know the answer to this but I think you
know people want me to ask it do you
think that you could play in the NBA if
you didn't follow your your dream to
play in the NFL do you think you could
play in it in the NBA and be the same
miles gear that you are in the NFL in
the NBA
I think I got a good chance
I mean spending all my time my effort my
focus on basketball no losing all this
this muscle you know getting just you
know straight lean and don't adjust
myself to that game I definitely think I
could have you know been a lead player
but you know looking at the you know the
contract I got now I'm definitely
blessed and in the situation I'm in
regardless of you know anything else
that's happening and I know the Browns
would much rather I play some golf like
you than uh be hooping an off-season
yeah I think over time man you just you
just love you're like it's a thing with
golf you know they always tell us coming
into the NFL like play golf play golf
like pick up the sticks like and it just
takes some time once you really like
get that bug and you really just really
fall in love with golf man it is nothing
like it man and I'm sure you said the
same thing about basketball who is Lee
who is the best NFL basketball player
now last week I had Mike Evans now you
play with Mike right
Mike is cold
he played with Mike Evans so before we
say you know who's the best basketball
player in the NFL I know Mike you know
he watches the show
you know I just you know I this is no
disrespect to Mike Evans but this is
from Miles Garrett Mr Mr Mr dunks and
sex
who is the best basketball player in the
NFL in European
man
I mean Mike's up there I don't know I'm
taking myself out the equation yeah I I
knew you would though I knew you would
but if you was I you would get my vote
man there's no disrespect to like Mike
or anything he goes but it's good that
you you take yourself out of the
equation who else you got for your boy
man DK's pretty nice DK Metcalf uh obj's
good at everything any anything obj
touches my man's got good at soccer he's
good at basketball
base I mean come on now my man do it all
uh
foreign
I can think of Mike might be number one
Bill and he didn't play he didn't he
didn't start playing football until his
senior year in high school that's well
he had played before he told us he told
us last week that he had played before
but you know he was always serious on
basketball and then his his senior year
he picked up football got a scholarship
and you know the rest is history
um
any pickup stories like with any other
did you ever play against Mike or DK or
you know any of those guys I know y'all
probably got a basketball goal in the
Browns facility so you can see like obj
and the guy shooting around you got any
stories you ever dunk on anybody
so I don't think anybody on the the
brown facility we start pulling out the
hoop like this year this year and last
year so I didn't really get to catch
anybody under the rim you know it's
really just shooting contests
Jacoby actually got a nice shot okay
I've seen some seen some uh some shots
from him I've seen seen the deform he
actually looked pretty nice
man so Jacoby man I played Jacoby a
couple of times and he is so hard to
tackle and we was on the bus riding back
home right after the game after we
played Johnny Detroit and I'm like man
like bro why is it so hard to tackle
this guy they was like man you know I
used to play point guard I was like you
know he's one of the best basketball
players in the league so his little
subtle movements and he ain't gonna get
you no sack I'm like man what you mean
he's like they was like he's like dead
in college man he ain't never give up no
sex so I feel a little bit better you
know about that man but miles you known
as a renaissance man you are you know
you are very talented and you you really
put your energy into a lot of things man
I you know I feel the same way about
myself I I'd like to be multifaceted and
I don't like to just be in a box of just
a football player I like to I like to
save you know football is just something
that I do
football is just it's something that I
do with my with my with my time it's not
like who I am and you are just saying
wait man you you have a lot of fun
interest you know you you're being in
the Poetry big in the basketball of
course science
um dinosaurs if you didn't play football
what do you think you would be doing
what what you would be the miles Garrett
of
what
and like you said like football is to me
like a it's a gift it's a set of
abilities it's a privilege like it's
that's not who we are it doesn't Define
us so we have so much more that we've
we've grown into and that Who We Are
for me no I would probably be you know
kind of doing the same thing but just
give my my time more to it you know
being you know give myself completed
with paleontology you know writing more
poetry be be more uh Progressive about
you know publishing that and being more
forward with it
uh
I'd be a little bit more of a World
Travel I'd be doing doing a lot more
digs I've always wanted to you know do
some digs um you know Montana uh and
Alberta go to Morocco no go to no places
like that and uh go go and do uh fossil
hunts so that's always interesting me
and uh I always I wanted to to write
children's books as well and I've been
on the process of doing it for like over
almost two years now and I'm just trying
to get it get it perfect get the get the
the best uh
idea I can on paper and some of that
stuff just it's always you know stuck
with me and it's always meant a lot to
me it's always you know kind of been
instilled with my parents and you know
my parents parents and uh you know
giving back and you know part of that no
philanthropic uh like need that I have
to give back it's just like it's just
you know always been of my nature and it
just comes this comes easily from to do
stuff like that and so the platform that
we have just just makes it so much more
accessible makes myself more accessible
to to do that for others who can't you
know do as much for themselves
man that's that's amazing man
um I always like I always like to think
about the the great quote that Uncle Ben
had told Spider-Man he told Peter Parker
on Spider-Man right he said with great
power girl comes great responses great
responsibility and we have a great power
to be in the NFL we have a huge platform
to be able to give back it would just be
it would just be wrong to just play
football every day and not really get
the most out of this and not give back
and not help and not try to create some
type of Charity or Foundation or to
raise awareness to whatever situation
that you have in your heart um I saw you
you had um you had went to Africa with
the Waterboys
went to Africa last year went to Kenya
and then year before that went to
Tanzania so really just you know cross
crossed over there right next to each
other and it's like
it was almost night and day you know as
far as like uh
you know the situations uh as far as
City Life As far as going out into the
brush and Safari you just see that like
Kenny is a little bit more Industrial
compared to Tanzania and a little bit
further further along the way and in
comparison like over here or in Europe
like they still have so much further to
go as far as you know progressing
towards that kind of you know life and
living situation but you know the the
positivity and the the light that they
bring you know the the like the wealth
of their soul there's just so much I
feel like it's so much deeper like on
average over there just because they
appreciate everything they're grateful
for for everything and it's just like as
much as I'm giving much time after I'm
giving like the just the experience and
the
the the life that they they pour into me
is is just as much as what I'm what I'm
doing and I'm giving to them and so it's
always a uh a awesome experience to be
able to go over there and give back
it is man you inspired me man um I saw
because you know you get caught up in
your own like um
you get caught up in your own efforts I
have Von's Vision we give it back
contacts glasses LASIK surgery and I
just you know my my time is always on
that and then you know to see Chris long
do some of the amazing things that he's
done and get acknowledged for it for the
Walter
um Peyton Man of the Year and I see you
help out with that man it inspired me
like bro I want to go do that and I want
to go help and I want to go see and you
know the um information that was passed
I don't wanna I don't want to mess up
you know the quotes but you know they
said over they said it's a huge
percentage of the world they don't even
have access to running water and the
water the fresh water they had to have
they have to walk miles to go get it and
it just puts things in perspective for
me because I can go in the bathroom
right here and turn on the sink and wash
my hands with it and hop in the shower
and wash my hair and you know it's just
it's just there and it's so easy for
people to you know take
um advantage of that we got food and
abundance we can we can go in the pantry
and get whatever we want we you can get
on doordash app and have it delivered to
our our house so you know seeing the
efforts that you did with that and Chris
Longman it really put things in
perspective to me man and I'm so
appreciative so appreciative you know to
have the the life that we have man and
I'm so appreciative to be in a situation
to help others man so I've always
admired admired that about you man and
you know it's not all about getting sexy
even though that you run them up it's
not all about getting sex and doing all
the wonderful things that you do on and
off the football field it's always about
you know helping somebody else man and I
admire that about you miles for sure man
you love dinosaurs
um you know the crazy thing is it's not
really dinosaurs for me that I love I
just like researching extinct animals
like it fascinates me that 99 of all the
animals that have ever lived on this
Earth are Instinct yeah yeah so so I do
um you know I look up re I research like
you know the uh the Nast Eagle you know
one of the biggest eagles that has that
has ever like you know flown the skies
and his his main prey was the Moa it's
kind of like an emu it's like a big uh
it's like a big bird yeah
you know about that man and you know
dinosaurs for you is is uh is your thing
man
um what he's just always been like that
since you're a little kid like because
you when you're on the football field
you attack you attack like a
velociraptor or you know or a T-Rex or
or something man like has has it always
like interests you or it always has man
I mean as far as you know dinosaurs no
my love Grew From you know watching
believe no Lost World Jurassic Park uh
that first time and then watching the
original you know as I got older because
I grew up on the second one because it
came out after I was born and then you
know I went back retroactive
retroactively and watched the first one
but like that love for dinosaurs like
you said it turned into like a love for
just like ancient animals and extinct
animals and so now I know about you know
the the Moa as well I know about the
Tasmanian Tiger the
the the ground sloth like stuff like
that like even stuff that that was
you know here while we were still here
all those animals were here while we
were still living and you know they they
wouldn't extinct though
and in some cases as a side effect of
what we were doing in in history so it's
it's also fun to not only you know go
back and see those animals that are like
you know 60 66 67 million years old to
130 million years old to stuff that was
here no just four or five thousand years
ago or like in you know in the last ice
age stuff that's you know La Brea Tar
Pits you know they they dig out new
fossils and new remains all the time of
stuff that was you know living alongside
us and that we we hunted now we that we
ran from that we that we strategized to
to go attack like we do every every day
so it's kind of crazy like the kind of
things that we we had to to to face the
kind of adversity that we had to face
from day to day just for all these
different types of animals and the the
the really problems that they they
provided towards us because you know
there was there was a lot of you know
good ones a lot of a lot of like
herbivores that didn't bother but there
was a lot of hunters that you know we
didn't have shelter from and that we we
had to we had to find a way around
man it's crazy to for me I I just I like
imagining like what life was like
with these animals like you said with
like living amongst them like I like to
just imagine how cool it was
um the great passenger pigeon it used to
be so many pigeons like it used to black
out the sky and they were hunted to they
were hunted to Extinction and this is
like this is as early as like the early
1900s like that I don't want to like
quarter I gotta look it up but it was I
think it was like 1930 or 1940. it was
huge that when they were migrate they
would black out this guy and it's just
it's just it's just cool for me to
imagine like you know now we see pigeons
on the ground we're like man it's just a
pigeon but they used to it used to be so
many of them that they used to just
black out the sky and they were
um hunted to Extinction and I think you
know you got to be aware of stuff like
that so it doesn't like happen again
yeah it doesn't happen again we got so
many amazing creatures that are left on
this Earth that I just you know I love
researching whether it's on in whether
it's uh you know the Cuttlefish or
whether it's you know anything I just
like knowing what type of mysteries that
this world has for us because it's the
only one and it's not like we it's not
like we can go nowhere I just like to
know what we're here we don't get the
running back anywhere else
Yeah man so what's what's crazy is that
like I had this I had this like same
exact talk with someone this this summer
about the pastor pigeon like how
abundant it was like how it blocked out
like the the sun when when they like
when they uh migrated all at the same
time and like like it's still like
mind-boggling because you see like swans
of birds like you know flying through
from time to time migrating and you
think like yo that's a lot of birds like
you see them sitting on the line and
they move at the same time but like it's
hard to like even fathom like the amount
of birds that it would take flying
together to where you just couldn't see
the Sun for an exterior extended you
know period of time and they were like
abundant from like the bottom of the U.S
to like halfway through Canada and like
they had a huge like population no throw
North America and now they're completely
gone and that's a like as a result of us
yeah absolute result of us
it's uh you know it's you know it's it's
extremely
you know it's I wouldn't say of course
it's sad and if but at the same time
it's just
it just shows you like we have to do
better man and it's not only just with
birds but it could be um
it could be greenhouse gases or fossil
fuels or like you know we got all these
of course we it's a lot of problems
going on in the world and you know but
global warming some people don't even
believe in global warming or any of that
stuff man but you know it's it's just
it's just extremely humbling to think
about like we are the ones doing this
it's not like
somebody else is coming like we like if
if humans were here if humans weren't
here it'd be so many animals so many
plants it'd be so beautiful
um but at the same time like we have to
live too we just gotta find a a better
way to uh coexist with some of the
beautiful and interesting animals that
we have
um that was one of my passions too so
it's good to like you know talk to you
about that man
um dinosaurs
um this right here is this game that we
want to play are you up for a game
I'm up for it let's do it this game that
I'm about to play right here is called
guess the dinosaur you know I'm sure
that you will run through all of this
but I just wanted to see I just wanted
to test it out it will put it up on the
screen right here for us
this is right here it's Gotta this is
this is the easy one that's on the
Jurassic Park all the uh this on
Jurassic Park everybody know this one
what's his mind yeah nice nice little
simple live little triceratops no
Triceratops you know I think uh land
before Tom this was uh this was Sarah
too
um you watched land before Tom the
cartoon of course yeah they got ducky
and I think that was Sarah the
Triceratops on there I might be a
mistake this uh the second one right
here the second dinosaur we got here
you had this on your birthday cake so
you gotta you gotta know this one right
here he said I had on my birthday cake
but uh yeah when I get a sack at home
actually this is the animal that pops up
on the like the Jumbotron yeah like
coming out like uh the Jurassic Park
Gates so Spinosaurus is my favorite and
I can't miss it
that's dope man that's dope man so when
you get a sack at at the Brown Stadium
they play the the whole sound and the
Roar and all of this stuff yes
it comes out the gate and then I'm
standing next to it
that's cool man
this uh third dinosaur that we got
you know it doesn't have the frill like
it did in Jurassic Park but that's still
a Dilophosaurus
this is the one where he was in there
he's tried to pet it and it just it like
spit in his eyes yeah it made like a
little sound
yeah
he made the little sound at him he had
to back up
Dilophosaurus was showing man and this
uh fourth dinosaur that we got right
here
um
you see the
I can't really see the the hands I can I
can see the largest it's the largest
land carnivore to have ever lived
well I can't say that with confirmation
because I know Spinosaurus existed and
it was longer
and I know T-Rex was believed to be
heavier but not quite as long but in
between is speculated to be
ignosaurus
they we I we might be wrong just
gigantosaurus
Giganotosaurus hey dog yes sir we yeah
we was wrong on this one right here man
hey hey we can't be uh testing miles on
here on the on the dinosaurs man for
sure man
I appreciate you man Dinosaurs the way
that they hunt and they go after the
prey it's kind of how
you know we feel where we're on the
football field my
when I'm when I'm on the football field
when I'm past Russian I like to have an
offensive mindset I like to feel like
you know I'm the one on attack and you
know the offensive line is trying to
stop me and they might have like a a
running back come chip or uh they might
line up the the tight end and this
formation I just gotta run around it I
gotta find a way to get to the
quarterback as fast as possible
um you know the art of pass rush what is
you know this is something I always ask
like the past rushes that the pastor of
summit and I'm sure I've asked you this
before but you know on the Von cast it
has we have to have a segment where me
and you talk about pass rush what is
your mindset when it comes to Russia in
the past obviously you have all these
different size past Russians and people
get it done in so many different ways I
feel like you get the most traction from
really
from really researching and really
watching and really listening to other
pass rushers mindset when they're on the
football field what is your mindset when
you're rushing to pass
it's like you know
it's like Hunters talking to each other
you know before they go out and hunt
deer or whatever you know getting get an
idea where it's at and where you need to
be the location all right this worked
I feel like that's us as pastors talking
to each other
and sometimes you gotta also you know
you can also learn from the prey you got
to watch it you gotta observe it and I
feel like that was my first year uh you
know spending my time with Joe Thomas
I don't want to call him pray because he
wanted her best to ever do it but I mean
he at the end of the day if he was on
the other team he'd be an OP
so just listen to him you know how he he
will react to the the uh
pass rush moves I was getting them the
the way I was coming up my angle of
departure
uh you know my hands and if I was doing
a long arm or a swim or you know
whatever you know how how he was going
to react to all that and then he would
break it down for guys
uh that that we are facing that wheat
and so you know whether he was you know
shooting his hands or he's a rapper or
he was you know he was kicks in or he
was turning you know you know the the
angle his departure and how he kicks
know whether he likes to you know vary
it up a little bit
for me I feel like you know all that is
great no I like to have that on my the
back of my mind where they you know he
might you know switch up or not but
you know I want to know his kick I'm
gonna know where his hips are I'm gonna
know what kind of hand puncher he is
after that I dictate everything else all
that stuff no he's not gonna change
uh before I get off the ball this is all
that he's that's been like ingrained in
him you know through his time in college
and football where there's change uh NFL
well that's changed no I don't know but
when I get off on the ball I want to
dictate the pace I'm going to apply
pressure
and I want him to feel like damn he's
he's on me right now
so he has to make a decision you know am
I am I going to turn my shoulders in
that case you know I'm gonna you know
stick the long arm and try to throw him
by I'm gonna try to spin back inside
is there a chip here now I might I might
uh use a chip to beat him inside whether
to without to spin back inside or like I
just you know
plant off the right and then like side
step or or Euro back into the to the to
the inside B Gap
but you had a you had a but you had a
crazy one versus the Bengals like and I
have I had one against the Chiefs I was
like man I see the running back the
running back is about to chip me so that
mean the slide got to be going away so I
ran up the field the running back came
up he chipped me I spun inside and I'm
like man like I I got here on this this
is versus Patrick Mahomes and then I see
you and you did the exact same move 50
pounds 50 pounds bigger than like 50
pounds bigger than me man like I was I
was blown away man I didn't want to
interrupt you bro but like the way you
get off the ball the way you're able to
spin and throw people by size and
strength and like then I'm just I'm a
huge I'm a huge fan of your game you
know that man like you know that man but
I you know I'll let you finish man I
ain't mean I ain't mean to cut you off
man but for sure when you said that it
just made me think about it like yo you
definitely be on all of that for sure
no I mean the the two people who I've
seen do that like to the best of like
of that ability is it's like you and LT
like being able to use the chip to your
advantage and like watching your film is
like it's like watching like a smaller
me because like I've always patterned my
game after you being able to like do the
same thing being able to dip you know
doing the ghost Rush being able to like
have a multitude of moves setting traps
like all that
you know I had all that came from you no
no come from the Aggie background you
know that have me following your
footsteps and I was like man my man has
the blueprint he's he's already paved
the way you know at the end of the day
you know just you know kind of you know
take a little bit from there you know
try to try to create my own path
um I am 40 pounds heavier 50 pounds
heavier like I'm able to use my power a
little bit differently you know try to
try to torque guys and use my hands a
little bit more than
you know just you know being a finesse
rusher but being able to like you know
not rely on it but you know use my
instinct when you know finesse isn't
working all right he's he's able to
recover on this on this uh outside Speed
Shop club and then you know I can always
rely on bringing my hand back inside and
and no longer I'm gonna buy or doing the
hunt move and then
no the guy's not there he's no no he's
so he's barbecue chicken but you know
knowing that
I got to be two guys three guys
regularly I know the first guy no
I I never worry about the first guy it's
really the second and third guys like
I'm I'm gonna get there I don't think
there's no uh attacking this league who
like is gonna take no one-on-ones with
us and and think he's gonna take the
majority
but as far as like applying pressure you
know getting to that move area uh making
him uh you know react how we want him to
react making him shoot his hands make
him turn like all that you know starts
with us
no getting off on the ball no Bruce
Smith always told me he said Amanda the
main thing is is get off you know we
when you're late no he you're just
allowing him to get in his set you know
getting his place and then he's
dictating you we dictate to them because
we're we're coming to them and so no
we're we're always on the attack even
though it's defense you know we're
always no no
pushing pushing the game forward and
making making things happen
man hey that just gave me goosebumps man
and that's hey uh kids at home that's
straight from the book of Rush
um chapter
um 95 miles Garrett he just he just gave
it to you
um verse three and four
um that's straight from that's straight
from the book of Rush man and another
thing that you do man like sometimes
power guys have a tough time with
finesse sometimes finesse guys have a
tough time you know converting over to
power bro and you do it so
you do it with so much
um you are so fluid with that like you
understand that if this guy don't
Embrace himself I'm gonna steamroll him
and back I'ma steamroll him back to the
quarterback so you anticipate him
bracing for himself and you hit the you
hit the Finesse the dip whatever it is
cross chop uh any uh double swipe like
you able to go to the Finesse whether
it's just a subtle shoulder dip and you
know like if I get off on the ball
they're gonna try to run with me and
you're able to get up to six or seven
yards and just spin back underneath bruh
so I'm a huge fan of you man and this is
it has been an honor and privilege to um
you know be able to witness you know
this right here
um Aggie Brothers like you know I want
to see you have as much success as you
possibly can man
um you know sex they come in bunches I
feel like whenever I watch you it's each
and every play we just played Just two
weeks ago and I'm on the sideline like I
don't know how Josh got all that I don't
know Josh
come on
bro what'd you get them you give
everybody such a tough time man
um you know I got some guys in the chat
um they they ask about
this is Will X Griggs he said Dragon
Ball Z or naturo Dragon Ball Z I mean
it's a classic I mean I feel like every
anime has or every Shonen anime has like
taking a little bit of Dragon Ball Z and
that like that atmosphere and the
intensity that it brings and like
brought it into itself
um will Graves also had a question he
said the hardest quarterback in the
league to tackle
I'll go first Jacobi percent man that
guy is
this guy and this guy all right does not
want to go down bro he's not your
typical quarterback bro like when we
played Joe I went I went for the ball he
came ready to throw the ball knock the
ball out of his hand he grabbed the ball
fall down I look over at the down marker
here a yard I said this guy right I was
like I was like I was like God dang he
got off on the ball and I'm seeing you
just run the hoop I'm like oh man Jacoby
thoughts like move do something like the
internal clock got to be gone and then
man like I see you I see you just
hunting and I'm like please just just
keep moving just go for it like just get
past the Denmark man that last driver of
the game man like I had so many good
jumps from the ball and I felt like
Jacoby he wasn't watching anybody but me
like he snapped the ball and he just
looking at me the whole time like dude
I'm like man I'm like bro like you gotta
pass the ball down the field I got a
good get off I beat the tight end and
the tackle and Jacoby saw me in just
side step then it was another play I
went for him I tried to tackle him but I
didn't get his arm all the way and he
just squeezed it out and threw it it was
cool because it happened to be holding
down the field anyways so I wouldn't
have got that sack anyway I'm like bro
I go again I try to I try to sack them
I'm blood rushing to God he spent out
and run the obviously way I say man this
guy he already big he already 245 pounds
bruh he just has that one too man like
man
don't be saying like I don't be feeling
the same way when we played y'all like
like I hit Dion Dion My Boy and again I
like talking to Dion and you know no we
we cool when we we kick it in the off
season but I hit him with a fake spin
off the chip
and this was like sheer Instinct like I
got into a situation where I started to
spin and I knew I wasn't in position to
complete it so I just came back out
and I'm thinking oh this about to be a
highlight
and some come I've been in the edge and
I see Josh still got the ball
and as I'm reaching out he's throwing it
so he he gets it out
I'm like ain't no way he he didn't see
me there's there's no way like his
internal clock is that good where he
just knew that I was gonna be right here
and Dion looked at me and said bro you
just hit me with a fake spin
yeah like
I think I like once you hit like a good
enough movie like yeah I got it like it
takes you to another level like you feel
like you're creating creativity is like
matching up with like everything like
your physicality like this game is going
to be a good one and I feel like I had
it like all these good rushes and he
should like staring at me just getting
the ball out it's like there's no way he
doesn't see me and he's not just
thinking of me
bro I've been feeling like that too man
and honestly like you the first guy that
we go against like
when you say when I see you sack Josh I
wasn't like
hey why y'all let him get a sec it was
just like okay like just limit it like
y'all just limited he gonna get his he
gonna get his now I gotta go out there
and get mug like you know everybody you
know she I'd be like man how you let
this guy beat you I go against you every
day like how you lit but with you man
it's just like okay y'all just limit the
damage like I'm gonna go right here and
I'm gonna get I gotta go get sex now
like you're the only player in the
league that I feel like that man I just
got so much respect for you and your
game man and um you know I don't want to
take up all your time man I got you know
a couple I got another game that I want
to play this game is called the cheat
code it's called the defensive the
defensive cheat code you a cheat code I
like to play GM you know I want to be a
gym when it's all said and done
um this is a passion of mine that has
grown over time you know of course I
don't want to coach I I'm I got too much
respect for these guys I've been I've
been in the locker room you know I know
how hard it is to you know to coach
these guys it's it's you know while I
have all I have everybody's time like
you got to respect these coaches man
because they poured their life into
coaching these guys and they they watch
these guys over and over and over and
over and they come in and they say
listen you want to be defensive player
of the year just do this and they come
in here and they do the opposite
everything
foreign
I got all the respect in the world I
want to be the guy that assembles great
teams you know I want a guy that brings
in the great coaches they brings in the
great players they brings in the great
athletic training athletic staff and the
strength and conditioning staff and I
want to bring in the great janitors in
the front office and you know I want to
be like the great hours too because yeah
coaches be working from like 6 a.m to
like oh 12 years but they don't get any
sleep they sleep up there they sleep
I I didn't show that one time and Kobe
was on the couch I was like coach
there's no way you've been here since I
left
they watch film over and over then they
watch next week's film and they come in
with the best game plan that they that
this is the best game plan
that that it gives us the best chance to
win and what we go out there and do what
we go out there and do we we don't get
the call and he just have to look at us
with everybody it's just like it does he
got the he got the perfect like perfect
plan in his head he's like all we gotta
do is execute and if someone don't do it
and then everybody look at him crazy he
just like he got taken on the chair
they'd be like all right we get them
next week yeah like I gotta simplify the
game plan I thought I already had it
simple for these guys I got I gotta make
it
myself
but you know with that being said man
this is the defensive cheat code game
and this is Defense number one you're
gonna be the common denominator on all
these defense I gotta have miles Garrett
on all of these defenses but this first
defense I got Micah Parsons miles
Garrett Chris Jones Jordan Brooks and
Patrick certain
I like this one because it's got Michael
Michael Parsons of course all these guys
on here cold but Michael Parsons Patrick
certain mom's good
Chris Jones Jordan Brooks on the same
team
hey I know for
eign
Jordan Brooks he gonna be able to lock
it to tight end too and Chris oh my God
like
a piece
it's gonna be crazy man this is Defense
number two
we got TJ Watts I'm scared the forest
Buckner
Matt Milano That's My Boy and sauce
Gardner this is this is this is a tough
one too I always like tall defensive
tackles like I play with Derek Wolfe for
a long time he was just able to command
all of that guard so when we run like a
text game that guard is going with him
there there's no way that this guard can
push off of Derek and come on like be
able to be able to still building
so I know running games with the forest
Buckner you and the force Buckner you uh
uh the force Buckner and TJ watt Matt
Milano what the best inside linebacker
in the league him and Tremaine Edmonds
two best inside linebackers in the
league they're gonna be able to lock up
he's a short tackler too so they're
gonna be able to play the run right here
too it's not gonna be nothing in the
sauce Gardner oh my God sounds guard and
Patrick Star Tan like up man I love
those guys man yo sauce is killing him
this year and I feel like when I watch
y'all's games I see like I always hear
Milano's name get called like multiple
times like he he's always in the thick
of things always making big plays like
it's it's like a joy to watch him play
like the position bro it is man he he
tackled well he plays the pass well he's
smart he's tough like he has everything
that you need from an inside linebacker
man that's Defense number two
Defense number three
Nick Bosa miles Garrett Dexter Lawrence
Fred Warner Jalen Ramsey oh my God geez
this was crazy too
this is crazy this is crazy
this is crazy
Jalen Ramsey you know I start with Jalen
Ramsey like he you know he's one of the
best corners in the league lock up any
receiver Fred Warner on the inside you
know similar to you know Matt Milano
could play to run past you ain't gonna
there's nothing that he can't do from
the inside linebacker position Dexter
Lawrence he gonna eat up the Run he'll
eat up the pass he's great running
versus past defense run defense got
miles Garrett Nick Bosa man this one
this one is crazy too this one's crazy
too man
then what what you got for defense
number four like Defense number four
of course you know I left some guys off
I got Max Crosby miles Garrett Aaron
Donald Devin white Darius Slay
ER
still you know what you know what I will
say with this mouse you know this is not
an indictment on anybody this is not
saying that this D this is nonsense this
is just simply a game that we play all
of these defenses can obviously go to
the Super Bowl and win it but you know
for shits and giggles
we got to come up with one of these
defenses
that we like and I guess I'll pick first
you know
this has nothing to do with anybody else
it's just this is just is this is just
me being biased because
I love Patrick certain
and I love Micah Parsons I want to go
with Defense number two because Matt
Milano is on there
but just for this game you know I love
Patrick certain I love Michael Parsons
and it's got miles Garrett I'm gonna go
with Defense number one
that's the defense that you know GM
Vaughn would like to go with all of
these could they all are capable of
doing exactly the same thing but this is
the defense that that I would pick you
know to go with do you have you want me
to run him back to see which one you
would pick to go with
you you ain't got to do all that I mean
respect to all these guys I ain't
Throwing Shade at any one of them I
think they're all
great football players man I think they
I mean they they all are at the very you
know top tier of their position and they
they play it all very well but you know
that that that first Squad like you said
that first Squad you know Patrick
certain Jordan Brooks
uh Chris no me Micah I mean Micah can
can move you know just about anywhere he
can Rush by anywhere he can drop back
like he's so versatile but so like
aggressive inverse and uh like
not not
man what is it I mean my man is is
really just all over the aggressive and
like uh
intense that's what I'm looking for man
my man is so intense like the the way he
plays the game like the energy he brings
to the game man you just
and you just watched like he's he's
never out of like he's always running
all over the field he's always you know
you know bringing it from you know the
first snap to the last snap and then I'm
not saying that no not all these guys do
that but like you do you just see it
like when when he like when he decides
to turn it on like you like you love to
watch and then Chris I mean he's always
a threat to to go and just Maul and
opposing no guard or Center for for two
three sacks
thanks for Tang on Lock Up
Jordan gonna be there when we need him
too he's he's gonna he's gonna you know
lock up with with any you know tight end
and also be able to to rush and and uh
Blitz where we need him to and make
plays all over the field no can go from
sideline to sideline and
you know I feel like I'm I'm top dog but
you know that you that's why I gotta
have you on all these defense
I'm gonna lead that there I feel like I
feel like I'm top dog but but man all
these guys you know they're at the very
top Center position
and I feel like number the group number
one is is taking you to multiple
multiple bowls and winning multiple
bowls it is man we got a lot of the
young two got a lot of guys on there too
man it's good to go man
um you know this is my last uh you know
segment with you you know I love I love
Halloween I know you love Halloween you
know this [ __ ] you dressed up as as
vekna from stranger things
um you know you are known for your your
quarterback graveyard tradition you know
you decorate your yard with gravestones
of of quarterbacks that he's sacked and
it was so dope and it was so inspiring
that we had the all-time sack leader
Bruce Smith
he did it as well and whenever you can
get Bruce Smith on board like you know
like bro you you know you're doing
something crazy man it was crazy because
I wanted to do it too but I was like
dang why did I think of that like miles
had already did it man dang he beat me
to it man I wanted to do it like a
little how you collab on that one man
I wanted we could ride with Bruce with
that graveyard then
I didn't want to be I just didn't want
to be that guy man because you know
sometimes when it's just so dope and
like you just try to do it too it just
it just it don't hit the same because
you already did it you know what I'm
saying so it was dope man and it
inspired me to want to do it was like
man miles already killed it man I can't
do it man like but but of course Bruce
can do it all time sag leader man and
you know both of those is crazy you know
with all the quarterbacks that you've
set
and all the quarterbacks that I say
it's one quarterback that I haven't
gotten that you haven't gotten that
we've both played
this year as a matter of fact I I we
both played this guy this year and I
didn't get him and you didn't get them
I've sacked a lot I got a lot of sacks
and leaks like a lot of quarterbacks you
them crushed and sacked a lot of
quarterbacks in this league this is the
one quarterback that neither me or you
haven't got
who you think it is
true this year
no you played them
dang okay give me some colors give me
some colors for this
um colors is uh teal
teal oh yeah you're right you're right
yeah
it's
two of man me neither me or you haven't
gotten tour bro
um you know you got all the sex in the
world I got I got a lot of sex that is
the one quarterback that we haven't
gotten
if I knew a quarterback if I if I could
tell your quarterback that was like
looking at me during the play
instead of looking downfield that would
probably be the guy when I talked to him
after the game he said there was no way
in hell he was gonna let me uh put him
in that graveyard I said yeah I know I
mean the man's a baller the man is
killing it this year and uh he did he
didn't want to let me get one and uh I
mean their dolphin line is is pretty
non-stop as well so yeah that kind of
stuff we got to change that though I got
another shot of these guys in two weeks
we got the Jets next week and then we
got the Dolphins the week after that at
home so I you know I have another shot
man and I got I got you one boy I'm
sorry I get I get it for both of us my
boy Hold It Down For Us man you got to
do it for for the Aggies
man it is an honor and a privilege to to
have you man like I said man before we
even got on here man if it's anything
that you ever need from me man if it's
just the video that you want me to share
for somebody man and you did the past
fresh Summit for me
um you got on the Von cash for me man
and you know coach uh Sherman told me
back when I was in college at Texas A M
he's had a a friendship is not somebody
that just takes and takes and takes it
it goes both ways you give and take you
give and take and I feel like I just
been taken from you miles I feel like
I've just been taken from you man if you
ever need me for anything man I am dead
serious about this just let me know man
if it's just a simple phone call to
anybody or Zoom son what man I got you
man whatever you need from fun man I'm
in debt to you man like even if it's
down the road when you start having kids
and stuff you want me to come dance at
your daughter wedding man like I I'm I'm
in debt to you man it is an honor and a
privilege to have you on my show man
fellow Texas and them fighting the Aggie
man hey I I appreciate Tom and I wish
you all the success in the world man I
love and I appreciate you my boy keep
going G thank you man y'all clapping up
for miles gear
man love and appreciate you dog I really
do and uh I mean you've given a wealth
of of knowledge and experience to me and
many other rushers and I know we have a
unique connection relationship and so
somewhere down the line I'm I'm gonna
call this favor in but until then man I
just appreciate what you do for all of
us and uh it's just a pleasure to be be
on this this uh this podcast too man
hey thanks miles I appreciate you man
I'll see you soon my boy yes sir we got
fan questions coming up right we have 14
12 at 14 12. he says do you think the
Giants will make the playoffs yes
they got Brian dayball
these boys got Brian Day ball right here
man you know he he's one of the the best
offensive models in the league yes I
think they will bounce back I think they
will go to the playoffs I think honestly
everybody in the NFC East uh division
we'll go to the playoffs wait wait let
me think
the Commander's got a
the Commander's got to do a little bit
of work but they are working and they
are winning games and they beat the
Eagles so
if they can do what they continue to do
I feel like everybody in the NFC east
team
the Philadelphia Eagles the Dallas
Cowboys the commanders and the Giants
will be able to make the playoffs so yes
I think I think the Giants will be able
to make the playoffs
um this is June or this juniors
uh there's a junior spawns Juniors he's
using actually crazy man Judy responds
to what great dens do you look up to the
most
um
honestly
I am a big fan of DeMarcus Ware Derrick
Thomas uh Bruce Smith alt all of those
guys but it's not necessarily the older
guys that I pay attention to and I'd
like to pay attention to the young guys
it's ringing off sacks I like to be
around the young guys I like to stay
inspired and and motivated by these
young guys because these young guys are
the future so I feel like the old guys
are really just trying to chase those
guys it just ages you instead I like to
to be like down here with the young guys
the guys are still fighting and ringing
off sacks I like to be around the Micah
Parsons and um you know the miles
Garretts and the TJ Watts I like to be
you know around the max Crosby's and you
know the younger pass rushers you know
what I'm saying the Bradley chubs I like
to be a Reynolds guy so I can feel young
and be young and like still ring off
sacks and get that that inspiration like
they be doing man like I feel like once
you get complacent and feel like you
think you know it all like that's when
it starts to become a downfall and in my
opinion so oh that's why I have a
password Summit each and every year
um it's not the Von Miller teach Clinic
it's just a place where we can go all
the passwords can go and we can just
bounce ideas off of each other I can see
them rush they can see me rush and if we
can just get one thing from each other
you know it is it is a good Summit
um you know this week
I'm not gonna be able to play against
the Patriots but this week is going to
be a tough matchup I can tell you that
right now
um Matthew judon
I I'm never afraid uh for my guys
because I feel like we prepare but the
guys that that make me nervous is of
course Matthew judon he can just like
when we play Miles Garrett and just like
last week when we play Aiden Hutchinson
like those guys can just single-handedly
wreck the game because I know this
because I see the game through their
point of view and I feel like I can do
that to the other team so Matthew judon
makes me nervous
um
Mac Jones makes me nervous because when
he's on his game he's one of the best
quarterbacks in the league
um Trent Brown makes me nervous because
when he's on he is the best tackling
League it could be right Taco left Taco
he's the best whenever he's on and that
is a unique situation to be in because
he controls it Trent Brown controls it's
up to him not who he plays it's
literally up to him if he wants to be
the best to ever play in the history of
everyone if he wants to be the best
offensive lineman to ever play this game
Trent Brown can do it and he puts his
mind to it and he doesn't give up any
reps there's nobody that's going to stop
him from doing it like I don't care what
Russia goes against Trent Brown
he can be the best if he wants to do it
it's a lot of guys that are the best
depending on what teams or opponents
they go against or Escape like it
doesn't matter what Russia goes against
Trent and he's on there is nothing that
God can do the guy is six eight 360
pounds and he moves just as quick as any
defensive end
if Trent is on he's the best so those
three players makes makes me nervous I
saw uh Hunter Henry go crazy he makes me
nervous but never afraid
um never never afraid like we got Josh
Allen we got Josh Allen we got Matt
Milano you know what I'm saying
tradevius white is playing more we can
we're getting Tremaine Evans back this
week we got Ed Oliver we got Stefan
Diggs uh Gabe Davis
we got Dawson Knocks we got we got all
these guys I could never be afraid but
you know they made me nervous and on top
of that we got coach McDermott man like
coach McDermott coach Frazier
um Ken Dorsey like bro these guys are
insane my boy
um so
you know I just uh I wanted to give a
little preview going to this game
um
you know I will drop some other news a
lot of guys a lot of people said that
you know the obj sweepstakes we were
gonna be down and out
obj's taking a visit
obj's taking a visit this Friday
yeah he's gonna be here everybody said
uh everybody was like oh no oh he's the
Cowboys hey man it ain't over till it's
over you know he's going to see the
Giants us and the Cowboys and I think
when he comes here I don't think he's
gonna leave
that's just my that's just my point of
view you know this is how I feel about
it I think you know we made it this far
out of all the sweepstakes we got all
the way to this point I don't think he's
leaving you know it's not over for me
you know I'm gonna be back at some point
so you know everything that we planned
for at the beginning of the Season still
out in front of us
um you know it is an honor and privilege
to come here and do this Von cash with
you guys each and every week like Cheese
Louise man
like I'm so blessed man it's such it's
such a blessing to be in this
environment with you guys and be able to
have a platform to talk to my fans man
it's super cool man and um you know I
always like to dedicate you know each
week
um
this week last week I dedicated last
time I had devoncast I dedicated it to
Bill's Mafia
um
you know this week
I dedicate this game
to all the coaches out there like even
the coaches that we're going against
even the coaches that we have on our
team even past coaches that have coached
me
um you know you got Jeff Saturday just
boom popping and coaching here head
coach it is not that easy
um coaching is one of the most mentally
emotionally
um challenging jobs it challenges your
patrons you have to really be a teacher
um you got guys that have been the man
their whole entire life and you you
spend countless hours upon hours you
know everybody's not the head coach
everybody's not the coordinator
everybody's not the position coach you
got gas and assistants that that pour
their whole heart and life into this
[ __ ] man and um you know this week
I would say going against you know Bill
Belichick one of the the best coaches to
ever coach
um this this game is for all the coaches
out there man um I respect you
um you know I appreciate all the coaches
that have coached me before all the
coaches that are coaching me now and all
the coaches that will continue to coach
me throughout my career man this one's
to you coach McDermott coach Washington
coach Frazier coach Marcus West
um you know here with the Buffalo Bills
this this week is for the coaches man
you know I appreciate y'all man I know
my teammates and my colleagues will say
the same thing about their coaches man
this is coaches week this is coaches
week this week man
um and it's an honor and privilege to be
here with you guys man this is the Von
Cass
I love you guys man and I'm out
[Music]